what up reject nation welcome to the real
rejects youtube channel my name is sally
you can call me salamander if you want to but
uh only if you subscribe so those are the rules
it's free go ahead and hit that subscribe
button why wouldn't you because then we can
be on a nickname basis you know what i mean you
can follow me at sally lamonico on instagram or
my own youtube channel which is you guessed it
sally lamonico i am doing a marvel movie marathon
on this channel i'm super excited about it we are
still on phase one so this video is going to be
me watching thor so if you are new to the channel
or if you haven't seen any of my previous videos
you can go ahead and check them out i have
watched iron man i've watched the hulk iron man
2. so yeah you can keep up with me if you click
that notification bell so that you know when my
next reaction is up we will be going in order and
if you're enjoying this series you can watch the
full movie with me you can sit down grab a bucket
of popcorn watch the whole entire two-ish hours of
these movies if you go to the real rejects patreon
that's patreon.com the real rejects greg and john
have a bunch of other cool on there if you want
to check them out full movie reactions and full
tv show reactions actually so there's a lot of
good stuff on there definitely check it out if
you are curious also if at any point you enjoy
this reaction please give it a like it really
does help the algorithm and you know it is free
you know to do so why not quick shout out to
prepper for editing together the highlights of
this video we really appreciate you here on the
real reject so thank you so much from the bottom
of our hearts and now it is time to watch full
oh that's not cringy it's probably cringy
i thought you said it was a subtle
i'm with her on that one
imagine hitting a hot guy with your car
from space from a realm of cold and darkness
came the frost giants
the cold never bothered me anyway it's like elsa
couldn't he just ice all of them
our armies drove the frost giants
back into the heart of their own world
impressive last great war ended we withdrew
from the other worlds and returned home asgard
it's like the upside down but
instead of hell it's heaven
i'm getting ribbon doll vibes from lord of the
rings the frost giants still live when i'm king
i'll hunt the monsters down and slay
them all a wise king never seeks out war
do you swear to cast aside all selfish ambition
and to pledge yourself only to the good of
the realm i swear a man that's not selfish
to proclaim you
frost giants
how did they get through
yeah they broke into the weapons vault
if the frost giants had stolen even one of
these relics they didn't well i want to know why
his face thinking only as a
warrior this was an act of war
but a few doomed to fail look how far they
got we will find the breach in our defenses
and it will be sealed as king
of asgard but you're not king
listen to your father
his facial expressions kill me i think you're
right if they found a way to penetrate asgard's
defenses once who's to say they won't try again
next time with an army we're going to yodenheim
man if disney made a whole
land that looked like asgard
that would be sick i would go heimdall
may we pause never as an enemy slipped
my watch until this day i wish to know how
that happened and you trust him why if your
return threatens the safety of asgard by foster
will remain closed i have no plans to die today
i thought they just like hit the ground hard they
landed nicely how did your people get into asgard
the house of odin is full of traitors stop
and think look around you we're outnumbered
know your place brother oh bro go now while i
still allow it run back home little princess
please make it a challenge for
me dude shut up because they will
oh my god
nada
oh my god we must go
see now you're just gonna piss them all off
ah
he could kill his friends doing that oh my god
uh oh god that's a way to do it
forgotten everything i taught you the
old ways are done you'd stand giving
speeches while asgard falls you're out of vain
greedy cruel boy you are an old man and a fool
you're gonna regret saying that
you are unworthy of these realms
you're unworthy
he's like humble yourself i now take
from you your power the name of my father
oh he's straight banishing him
whosoever holds of this hammer if he be
worthy she'll possess the power of thought
he's about to get a slice of humble pie
or a car what realm is this alpheim dornheim new
mexico you death threatened me thor was so punier
hi just taking a little blood how
dare you attack the son of god
bro
oh my god chill
you're no match for the mighty
they should have that at disneyland right by the
sword and the stone that would be cool well our
data can't tell us what it was like to be inside
that event and he can so we're gonna find him
okay i'm gonna look all over
new mexico right exactly
i love it
here comes the government per usual they're
gonna take the beer and run you must go to
the old father and convince him to change his
mind and if i do then what he's arrogant he's
reckless he's dangerous you saw how he was
today is that what asgard needs from his
i mean he's kind of right what am i you're my son
i'm blue in the aftermath of the battle
i went into the temple and i found a baby
left to die alfie's son you took
me for a purpose what was it
you know it all makes sense now why you favored
thor all these years because no matter how much
you claim to love me you're gonna have a
frost giant sitting on the throne of asgard
he just died just drink i like it
i know it's great right no though
asked nicely i meant no disrespect
all right well no more smashing deal
i have my wood the way he looked her up and down
like that nobody could lift it they said it was
radioactive i had my hands all over
it which way 50 miles west of here
we need to appropriate your records and all your
atmospheric data by appropriate do you mean steel
i'm on the verge of understanding something
extraordinary hey hey thank you for cooperation
that sucks father has fallen into the odin sleep
you can bring your urgent matter to me your king
the thursday thor's day you
think me strange yeah i do
good stranger bad stranger i'm not quite sure yet
she won't hit somebody else but who are you really
she's not looking at the road at all look what's
down there you think you're just gonna walk in
grab our stuff and walk out no i'm gonna fly out
oh almost took off his shirt
nice last chance wait i want to see this
hmm
no
some of the most highly trained professionals in
the world look like a bunch
of minimum wage mall cops
don't go anywhere
loki hmm tell me is it jodenheim let me explain
to father father is dead the threat of a new war
it was too much for him to bear freaking liar
the burden of the throne has fallen to me
now burden the truce with the otonheim is
conditional upon your exile couldn't we find
a way your mother has forbidden your return
this is goodbye brother i'm so sorry
hello [__] he was distraught when he found
out that you're taking all of our research
that was years of his life gone that still
doesn't explain how he managed to tear through
our security steroids he's a bit of a fitness nut
it's gonna be all right i'm taking you home now
nice dr selvik just keep him away from the bars if
they knew he was lying why'd they let him go where
are we going let's get a drink yes father okay
there we go i don't know if you're delusional or
if you're pulling some kind of con i don't care
just care about her i've
seen the way she looks at you
classic line lead you into odin's chambers
and you can slay him where he lies i
accept oh my god is he okay
he's fine no engine at all
oh i still don't think you're the god of
thunder what you ought to be bromance it
was all i could get back i'm sorry it's not as
much as i promised no no this is great this is
i don't have to start from scratch now thank you
that's cute you must finish what you started why
because you're right yeah look well i come from
a place where they're one in the same thing
she's in live with a god we must find thor
it's treason to help with treason
suicide thor would do the same for us
you would defy the commands of loki our king
break every oath you have taken as warriors
and commit treason to bring thor back yes
not too subtle is it you won't be able to
convince the scientific community of any of it
not without hard evidence found you
yeah you know i can't go well
my father is dead because of me i must
remain in exile your father still lives
i say for your act of treason you are
relieved of your duties as gatekeeper
and no longer citizen of asgard
and i need no longer obey you
is that one of starks
yourself
yeah try out running that
keep it distracted
oh no
oh
yes
no i will die her warrior's death
stories will be told to this day
live and tell those stories yourself hmm
that's a good line we must return to asgard
you have to stop loki what about you
do not worry my friends i have a plan
didn't he just destroy the
7-eleven and it's right there
i am truly sorry but these people are innocent
oh no
i broke his neck
at least you didn't get the liquor store
yes king
god
literally
donald i don't think you've been completely honest
with me know this son of cole son of core you stay
forward you can count me as your ally if you
return the items you have taken from jane stolen
give you my word i will return for you
yes your death came at the end of laffy
oh and your death came by the son of odin
i swear to you mother that they will
pay for what they've done today loki
oh no why have you done this to prove to father
that i am a worthy son i would have destroyed that
race of monsters you can't kill an entire race
what is this new found love for the frost giants
hmm forgive me
oh wow
dang he got there fast i should have
done it for you for all of us no loki
mic drop
i'm out it's gone
this is how every woman feels when a
guy ghosts her feel you can you see her
yes how is she
she searches for you hmm that's cute
it's over again i'm an idiot i did
not watch the end credits scene to
thor because i'm just like i'm a
little out of the loop you know
i'm going to watch the end credits
scene to thor now in a different outfit
hopefully it blows my mind
thor will return to the avengers yas
legend tells us one thing history another
but every now and then we find
something that belongs to both
uh what is it power doctor if we can figure
out how to tap it maybe unlimited power
loki what are you doing boy
well i guess that's worth a look
well i guess that's worth a look no
loki pretended to be bill nye okay yeah
that was worth me going back wow what a
little snake he's a little snake but he's still
hot it's confusing so okay that that seems like
a great setup to the avengers for sure and
captain america because doesn't that little
box thingy show up in captain america anyway
it's like the tesseract right is that what it's
called little tessie i wish i had seen that before
watching captain america but i am about to watch
the avengers so all right i liked it i enjoyed it
we got a little bit of low-key in there low-key
low-key you know think what's next is my uh review
of the movie so enjoy that so that was thor i
really enjoyed this movie my mom has been obsessed
with this movie like i remember when it first came
out she watched it all the time and i got sick of
seeing it on her tv i was like i don't get it um
but i guess i never really paid much attention to
it until now and now i understand why she always
says i need a horse great line i noticed there's
a lot of similarities between the lion king and
this movie actually and i love the lion king
that's just such a classic story loki obviously
reminded me of scar and thor reminded me of simba
even down to like him dangling on the cliff and
more specifically when loki was lying to him about
how it was thor's fault that his dad got killed
and i remember scar blamed simba for killing
his father and yeah there were definitely a
lot of similarities but i still really enjoyed
the dynamic of both of them in this movie it
was very unique in terms of the acting and
kind of how they both still love each other
through this because you can see both sides
clearly and where they're both coming from i feel
like yeah loki is set up to be a villain but you
can kind of understand why he feels the way that
he feels and why he does the things that he does
so i really enjoyed that aspect like he's a great
villain in that regard i also just really love
fish out of water stories they're so funny there's
always so much room for comedy and fish out of
water movies so thor being in new mexico instead
of you know being an asgard in another realm
was really funny just to see him interact with
americans and their ways of life versus where he's
from it's just it was really funny there was a
a lot of great comedic moments in this movie that
i enjoyed i really really like the script because
i would say in comparison to some movies i've seen
especially superhero movies a lot of times just to
create more conflict i feel like a lot of
characters make dumb you know decisions and i feel
like with this one a lot of times every decision
each character made specifically the characters
that are from new mexico i got it like that a
lot of it made science and a lot of it i felt
was realistic in a sense of what they would
actually be doing and what they would actually
be trying to achieve and how they go about it the
fact that it all kind of took place in one little
spot too and not like oh we have to save the
whole world like it was just this intimate sort
of story in this small town i think also grounded
it made it more realistic in a sense obviously the
story of him losing everything losing his power
losing the one thing that i feel like defined him
it's a classic story for a superhero movie to
lose the power lose the suit or lose something
that makes them feel like that's what defines them
and so even though it's been done a lot i still
enjoyed the way that this movie uh handled
it because i don't think it was as dramatic
as some other movies make it and so it was still
definitely fun and thor definitely didn't lose his
uh tenacity and his personality and of course
he changes in the beginning he's super pompous
and arrogant and then by the end he's very kind
but still strong which is great i also just
really loved the cinematography in this movie
there were a lot of really really great shots
specifically standing out to me is the scene where
thor tries to take his hammer out of the ground
and colson's standing there watching him with the
rain and he obviously didn't do it and then his
sadness of not being able to pick up his hammer
that doesn't sound as sad when i say it but out
of context i don't know that whole scene was shot
beautifully and there were so many shots i could
tell there's a term for it i went to film school
i'm blanking right now but where is it like a
dirty shot or something no what is it it's like a
term for it where basically the angles are off uh
dutch angle and that kind of always indicates that
there's something dangerous going on or something
uneasy about the situation i noticed that a lot
i just noticed the composition and the movie just
being beautiful and really enjoying it i also
just love that very human moment where he's like
let's go to a bar because i remember thinking that
earlier like after he couldn't get the hammer out
i was like he needs a drink and uh and then he did
so that was great i also really just loved acting
like chris hemsworth and tom hiddleston and oh
my god the whole entire cast did such a good job
natalie portman always makes i feel like sometimes
these sort of scripts can sound a little cheesy or
a little out there and i feel like she has a
a great way of being able to say her lines in
such a realistic way that she can make a cheesy
line sound good basically so that's great kat
dunnings i believe is hers her name is is kind
of the uh the everyman in this movie of what we
would all react to as you know a regular person
in a situation like that again i just think the
whole cast did such a great job so even though
there's lots of different types of movies kind of
in one i feel like they pulled it off
i think let me just also the chemistry
between chris hemsworth and natalie portman
amazing i love that her name is jane too because
it kind of reminded me of tarzan and jane he's
just this big guy from another world basically
and her name is jane i don't know if that
was done on purpose i don't know when these
comics came out i don't know but um i just
noticed that and thought it was kind of funny
so again like i loved the ending too i
think it's a great setup for the avengers
and i just feel like there weren't any weak
moments in this movie for me that i could think
of it was very fast paced every scene felt like
it was meant to be in this movie also with endings
it's really hard to have a good ending especially
one where you're trying to set up for another
movie because it's kind of like where do you
go from here but i thought overall this movie
was really enjoyable i now know why my mom watch
this movie all the time because it's it's very
entertaining so again thank you guys so much for
watching subscribe if you enjoyed this video and
there are plenty of other videos on this channel
if you would like to check them out by greg and
john they're great and give it a like thumbs
up same thing thank you guys for watching this
with me and uh i'm gonna go get a horse so i'm
gonna go to bed that's actually what i'm gonna do
so thanks for watching and i'll see
you for the next movie stay tuned bye